nous examinons aujourd'hui pour avis les
missions budgétaires relevant notre
commission nous sommes ravis de recevoir
une ministre qui nous est connu
puisqu'elle est directement issue de
notre commission madame la secrétaire
d'État chargée de la citoyenneté et de
la ville madame Sabrina
grestioubach sur la mission asile
immigration intégration je rappelle que
le 10 octobre dernier depuis le 10
octobre dernier pardon vous êtes en
charge auprès du ministre géralde de
Darmanin de ce portefeuille de la
citoyenneté après votre intervention
liminire nous entendrons la rapporteur
madame Blandine br
et nous entendrons ensuite les orateurs
des différents groupes pour une durée de
4 minutes et vos questions pour une
durée de 2 minutes madame la ministre
bienvenue à nouveau à la Commission des
LO vous avez la parole bonjour je suis
heureuse de retrouver ma maison
naturelle bonjour à tous monsieur le
Président mon cher Sacha madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés écoutez je suis très heureuse
d'être parmi vous ce matin pour vous
présenter les crédits de la mission
immigration asile et intégration
quelques mois seulement après le vote du
Parlement visant octroyer près de 15
milliards d'euros au ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outresères à travers
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur la Lop m sur
les C prochaines années je vous prie
d'excuser le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outresmèes qui ne peut être présent
ce matin mais dont chacun connaît
l'implication pour défendre les crédits
de son ministère pour
2024 le Gouvernement a souhaité vous
présenter un budget en augment de plus
de 7 % pour un montant total de 2,2
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
soit environ 10 % de crédit du ministère
sur le périmètre de laalopmie cette
augmentation représentera près de 147
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires par rapport à la loi de
finance de 2023 elle inclut les crédits
issus de la lopmi pour la période
2022-2027 y compris ceux du plan CR 3000
ce budget marque une nouvelle étape dans
les efforts conduits depuis 2017 pour
consolider notre capacité à maîtriser
les flux migratoires et lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière garantir
l'exercice du droit d'asile renforcer
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière dit Primot
arrivant il s'inscrit pleinement dans le
cadre de la Lop m avec une programmation
budgétaire inédite en 5 ans nous aurons
ainsi fait progresser les crédits
affectés à la mission et donc à la
politique migratoire de la France de
façon réelle et
inégalée comme vous le savez le budget
de la miss immigration asile et
intégration que je vous présente ce
matin repose sur deux programmes
complémentaires le programme 303
immigration et asile et le programme 104
intégration et accès à la nationalité
française le programme 303 immigration
et asile s'établit à hauteur de 1,7
milliards soit une augmentation de 17,7
% cette progression sensible reflète
pour partie le transfert des programmes
numériques et celui des places
d'hébergement pour réfugiés précédemment
assuré par le programme 104 mais aussi
165 millions d'euros de mesures
nouvelles le programme 104 intégration
et accès à la nationalité s'établit pour
sa part à 431 million d'euros la
diminution des crédits de ce programme
environ moins 20 % à par rapport à 2023
pardon correspond pour l'essentiel au
transfert que je viens
d'évoquer je veux par ailleurs souligner
que ce programme prévoit une
augmentation des places d'accueil en
2024 vous l'aurez noté il s'agit là d'un
équilibrage interne des actions
soutenues pour une plus grande
lisibilité et sans incidence sur les
grandes orientations de la mission en
effet cette année près de 65 % des
crédits seront consacrés à l'accueil et
à l'examen des situations de demandeurs
d'asile et des réfugiés les 1,4 million
d'euros concernés doivent permettre
d'assurer les dépenses d'hébergement à
la hauteur de 996 millions les dépenses
pour laallocation pour demandeurs
d'asile à hauteur environ de 300
millions et les crédits nécessaires au
fonctionnement de l'Office fr
de protection des réfugiés et des
apatrides environ 108 millions par
ailleurs 20 % des crédits sur soit les
431 millions pardon seront consacrés à
la politique
d'intégration ce sont 260 millions
d'euros qui seront mobilisés pour la
maîtrise des flux migratoires en
complément des dépenses dédiées à ces
missions par les budgets de la police
nationale de la police aux frontières et
de la
gendarmerie ce chiffre comprend
notamment les crédits alloués à la
politique des visas à l'aide au retour
ou encore au financement des lieux de
rétention enfin je souhaiterais rappeler
qu'un des piliers essentiels de la
politique portée par la Mission ei
réside également dans le portage de
plusieurs chantiers numériques pour un
montant de plus de 50 millions d'euros
visant à délivrer un service public de
qualité dans des délais
contraints naturellement mesdames et
messieurs les députés ce budget 2024
n'inclut pas les crédits qui seront
rendus nécessaires par les mesures du
projet de loi pour contre contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
que votre assemblée examinera très
prochainement il n'intègre pas non plus
ce rendu nécessaire par l'accueil et
l'accompagnement exceptionnel des
bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire qui ont fuit l'Ukraine au
mois de mars
2022 je veux souligner ici que la France
accueille aujourd'hui environ
73000 personnes dans cette situation à
contrario ce budget intègre la prise en
charge des coûts de la revalorisation
salariale décidée par le gouvernement en
septembre 2022
afin que les salariés du secteur privé
non lucratif bénéficient de l'équivalent
de l'augmentation de la valeur du point
d'indice de la fonction publicque cela
représente environ 19,4 million d'euros
sur cette mission sur le fond je tiens à
redire devant vous l'engagement total du
gouvernement pour une politique
migratoire plus efficace mais aussi plus
humaine je tiens ainsi à vous présenter
en quelques mots les grandes lignes et
les principales évolutions des crédits
de la mission en matière d'asile nous
souhaitons continuer à améliorer la
accueil et l'examin des situations des
demandeurs au total
138577 premières demandes ont été
enregistrées en 2022 soit un niveau
proche de celui de 2019 année où la
demande d'asile avait été la plus
importante en France depuis le début de
l'année 2023 la hausse de demande
d'asile s'est poursuivie elle atteint
environ plus 8 % mais le niveau de cette
augmentation est moins haut que dans le
reste de l'Europe où il reste proche
environ de 30 %. ainsi dans un contexte
de forte incertitude et de tension
internationale le gouvernement a établi
cette programmation en anticipant la
possibilité d'une demande de l'ordre de
160000 demandeurs d'asile en 2024 pour
un montant environ de 300 millions
d'euros au titre de la loocation de
demandeurs d'asile Lada pour y faire
face nous souhaitons ainsi agir plus
particulièrement sur deux axes
l'amélioration des délais de traitement
de la demande d'asile par l'OFPRA
disposant depuis de depuis 2020
d'effectifs renforcés pour lui permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs fixés par le
ministre je RA rappelle ici que depuis
2017 la dotation annuelle de l'OF pra a
augmenté de 43 millions d'euros et près
de 250 et près de 250 équivalents temps
plein des ETP ont été recrutés par
l'opérateur la poursuite de l'évolution
du dispositif national d'accueil DNA
pour les demandeurs d'asile et les
réfugiés elle en revanche passe par le
renforcement des capacités d'hébergement
au niveau national ce seront donc 1500
places au total sur l'année 2024 elles
permettront de porter le parc
d'hébergement à plus de 121000 places
soit 30000 places supplémentaires depuis
2017 en complément nous entendons
maintenir les 500 places dédiées au
sases d'accueil temporaire créé dans 10
régions de métropole pour accueillir les
personnes sans solution d'hébergement ou
de logement prise en charge dans le
cadre d'opération de mise à l'abré en
matière d'intégration ensuite nous
souhaitons poursuivre les efforts
engagés depuis 5 ans ceux-ci ont déjà
permis une augmentation du niveau
d'exigence en matière d'apprentissage
linguistique et civique dans l'attente
de du vote du projet de loi sur
l'immigration qui prévoit des mesures
forte pour renforcer l'intégration par
le travail et par la langue le
gouvernement a déjà prévu de renforcer
significativement les trois mesures
d'intégration suivante la poursuite du
déploiement du programme agir programme
d'accompagnement individualisé des
réfugiés vers le logement et l'emploi
déjà déployé dans la moitié des
départements pour généralisation d'ici
la fin de l'année prochaine le
développement des formations
linguistiques avisé professionnel la
poursuite du renforcement du rendez-vous
de santé en matière d'immigration enfin
nous mettons en œuvre un dispositif
refondu d'aide au retour volontaire
l'ARV pour plus incitatif via une
dégressivité dans le temps de montant de
l'aide pour accélérer les les
éloignements nous poursuivons nous
poursuivons également l'augmentation
très nette de nos capacités de rétention
dans le cadre défini par laalopmie pour
porter le nombre de places en centre de
rétention administrative à 3000 d'ici
2027 soit le double des 1500 places
existantes fin 2017 je veux souligner
que le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outresmères a récemment annoncé
l'implantation de 10 nouveaux cras de
plus de 100 PL chacun les efforts en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine seront ainsi réhaussés de 90
millions d'euros pour atteindre 261
millions d'euros en 2024 nous
consacrerons également près de 15
Millions d'Euros pour renforcer nos
moyens matériels
en en procédant à l'achat d'intercepteur
moyen de projection et en constituant un
étatmajor
dédié mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'actualité récente nous a encore une
fois montré l'importance de doter la
France des outils et des moyens
budgétaires pour déployer une politique
migratoire efficace pragmatique et
humaine nous devons donner à l'État au
préfet au services déccentrés les moyens
d'agir le plus efficacement possible
nous le devons à nos concitoyens comme à
celles et ceux qui demandent à venir
résider en France
à y trouver refuge c'est l'objectif du
budget que je vous présente aujourd'hui
et ce sera le but également du projet de
loi contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration que vous aurez comme je le
disais à examiner très prochainement
donc vous pourrez toujours compter sur
ma détermination et ainsi que celle du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes pour vrer à cette ambition et
maintenant donc je me réjouis de
répondre à vos questions je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre madame
la
rapporteur
merci appuyd merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers collègues
permettez-moi aussi de saluer
l'administratrice claire poncé qui m'a
beaucoup aidé évidemment dans ses
travaux les crédits consacrés à la
mission immigration asile et intégration
augmenteront en 2024 et ce pour la 7e
année consécutive alors ils c'élont en
effet en crédit paiement à 2,16
milliards d'euros contre 2 milliards
d'euros en loi de finance initiale pour
2023 en autorisation d'engagement
néanmoins les crédits diminueront de 34
% passant de 2,7 milliards à 1,7
milliards d'euros le programme 303
immigration et asile réunit la plupart
des crédits de la mission il finance les
politiques publiques relatives à
l'entrée la circulation le séjour et le
travail des étrangers ainsi que
l'éloignement des personnes en situation
irrégul
et l'exercice du droit d'asile les
crédits diminueront en 2024 de 37,5 % en
autorisation d'engagement mais
progresseront de 17,7 % en crédit de
paiement par rapport à la loi de finance
initiale pour
2023 l'action 2 garantie l'exercice du
droit d'asile finance notamment
l'allocation pour demandeur d'asile Lada
la dotation inscrite pour 2024 connaîtra
une diminution de 7 % le le projet
annuel de performance indique que cette
projection résulte de l'accélération du
traitement des demandes d'asile vous en
avez parlé Madame le Ministre diminuant
mécaniquement le montant de l'INDA
madame la ministre ma première question
pourriez-vous expliquer plus précisément
les raisons de cette diminution et les
hypothèses sur lesquelles celle-ci s'est
construite l'action 2 récupère par
ailleurs la dotation inscrite en loi de
finance initiale pour 2023 à l'action
numéro 15 accompagnement des réfugiés du
programme 104 et consacré au financement
des centres provisoires d'hébergement
des réfugiés le transfert de ces crédits
vise à regrouper l'ensemble des places
d'hébergement du dispositif national
d'accueil dans cette action à cette même
action le plafond d'emploi de l'Office
français de protection des réfugié à
patri l'au pra sera relevé de 17 ETPT ce
qui ne peut-être que salué car cela
permettra de poursuivre la réduction des
délais de traitement des demandes
d'asile les crédits de l'action numéro 3
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
sont en forte hausse de 46 % en
autorisation d'engagement et de 53,8 %
en crédit de paiement cette augmentation
des crédits porte principalement sur les
frais d'éloignement des étrangers en
situation irrégulière et s'explique par
la fin des restrictions sanitaires liées
à la pandémie ainsi que par une action
diplomatique auprès des paystiers pour
faciliter les retours et par l'impact de
l'inflation sur les prix des carburants
s'agissant du second programme le 104
intégration et accès à la nationalité
française qui comprend quatre actions
relatives à l'intégration des étrangers
en situation régulière les crédits sont
en baisse de 20 % en autorisation
d'engagement et crédit de paiement pour
s'établir à 431 million d'euros cette
évolution s'explique pour une large part
par la suppression de la totalité des
crédits de l'action 15 accompagnement
des réfugiés soit 121 millions d'euros
que je mentionnais qui ont été
transférés pour leur quasittalité au
programme
303 s'agissant des crédits de l'action
12 intégration des étrangers primo
arrivant je félicite le gouvernement
pour cette augmentation ambitieuse des
crédits de près de 29
%. madame la ministre je suis convaincu
de longue date que la formation
linguistique est une composante
essentielle de la politique
d'intégration des étrangers les
formations linguistiques sont financées
à la fois par l'action 11 dont les
crédits diminuent de 10 % et par
l'action 12 dont les crédit augmente
pourriez-vous me préciser comment
évoluera le budget consolidé affecté à
ces formations pour 2024 et quel sera
spécifiquement le budget consacré à la
composante linguistique du contrat
d'intégration
républicaine je note toutefois une
diminution de 17,8 % des crédits
consacrés à l'action 16 accompagnement
des foyers de travailleurs migrants
madame la ministre pourriez-vous nous en
dire plus sur ce point alors voilà pour
la partie purement budgétaire mes chers
collègues après avoir consacré donc mon
avis de l'an dernier à la procédure de
régularisation des étrangers en
situation régulière via la mise en œuvre
de la circulaire Vals de 2012 j'ai fait
le choix cette année de m'intéresser à
une des thématiques de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et plus
précisément j'ai souhaité évaluer le
régime juridique des fameuses OQTF ses
obligations de quitter territoire
français et en particulier deux axes
premièrement celui de leur exécution et
deuxièmement celui de la place qu'il
réserve à la notion de menace à l'ordre
public je remercie vivement le ministère
de l'Intérieur le président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat le sénateur
François Noël buffet la préfecture de
police de Paris celle du Rône le Conseil
national des barreaux et les
associations pour leur concours à mes
travaux avant toute chose mes chers
collègues je souhaite vous faire part de
ma principale conviction à l'issue de
mes auditions préparatoires je suis
convaincu qu'il est indispensable
devrait dans le sens de la plus grande
célérité possible en matière d'octroit
et de renouvellement de titres de séjour
ainsi que des d'exécution des TF alors
trop souvent je suis sollicité et je
suis sûr que vous aussi mes chers
collègues par des étrangers sur le
territoire de façon irrégulière depuis
de très nombreuses années et frappé
d'qtf alors que désormais et bien toute
leur vie est en France et que leurs
enfants n'ont connu que notre pays ces
situations sont insupportables et l'une
des priorités de notre politique
migratoire doit être d'y mettre fin
s'agissant en premier lieu de
l'exécution des OQTF je rappelle que de
plus en plus d'qtf sont prononcés chaque
année entre 2011 et 2022 le nombre d'qtf
a augmenté de 123 %. en 2022 au total
134000 au qtf ont été prononcés et dans
le même temps oui le taux d'exécution de
celle-ci ne cesse de faiblir et atteint
des taux qui peuvent légitimement
interroger 17 % 2015 12,2 % 2019 et 5,7
% au premier semestre 2021 dans le
contexte de de pandémie que nous
connaissions alors naturellement la
faiblesse de ces taux nuit à la
crédibilité de notre politique
d'éloignement et entraîne une
préoccupante perte de sens chez les
agents publics chargé du droit des
étrangers j'identifie dans mon avis les
différentes causes et formule le vœux
que nous avancions prioritairement sur
trois pistes alors la première piste
l'amélioration de l'obtention des
laisser passer consulaires via un effort
diplomatique multicanal au niveau
national comme au niveau européen la
seconde piste une meilleure connaissance
et un renforcement du recours aux outils
juridiques qui existent déjà par exemple
le refus de délai de départ volontaire
et l'édiction d'interdiction de retour
sur le territoire français et la
troisième piste la simplification du
contentieux des qtf en raccourcissant
notamment certains
délais s'agissant en second lieu de mon
analyse de la prise en compte de la
menace à l'ordre public dans le régime
juridique des otf je me suis intéressé
ici à trois aspects le premier aspect
c'est l'qtf fondé sur le motif de menace
à l'ordre public qui figure à l'article
l611-11 du cza et qui représente 7 % des
OQTF le second aspect c'est la place
occupée par l'ordre public dans les OQTF
fondé sur d'autres motifs puisqueune qtf
peut par exemple officiellement être
fondée sur un refus de titre de séjour
mais ce refus peut résulter de la
caractérisation d'une menace à l'ordre
public et le troisème aspect enfin la
priorisation du placement en centre de
rétention administrative des étrangers
représentant une menace pour l'ordre
public je juge cette priorisation tout à
fait est pertinente et je formule le
souhait qu'elle se poursuive et qu'elle
s'accompagne naturellement d'un
renforcement de la capacité de nos cras
nos centres de rétention administrative
je salue en cela la volonté du
gouvernement de porter le nombre de
places en cras à 3000 d'ici 2027 je
pense également souhaitable de renforcer
parallèlement le recours à l'assignation
à
résidence s'agissant du régime juridique
des TF à proprement parlé et de la prise
en compte de l'ordre public je pense
utile à St de ce qui est proposé dans le
futur projet de loi d'assouplir le
régime de protection existant contre les
OQTF je souhaite laisser à l'autorité
administrative et au juges la
possibilité d'apprécier in cononcretto
si un étranger doit faire l'objet d'une
octf au regard du niveau de menace qu'il
représente pour l'ordre public d'une
part et de sa situation personnelle et
de ses liens avec la France d'autre part
les protections qui existent aujourd'hui
dans le czda constituent un frein
parfois trop important et je serais donc
attentive aux dispositions du projet de
loi à venir relative à ce point je vous
remercie pour votre attention merci
Madame la rapporteur on passe aux
orateurs de groupe monsieur Ludic mendz
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la rapporteur
les flux migratoires restent importants
et leur maîtrise demeure un enjeun
essentiel pour lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière avec l'appui
de nos partenaires européens la France
dote d'outil et de processus efficace
l'accent est mis sur l'amélioration des
contrôles la lutte contre la fraude
documentaire avec par exemple
l'utilisation proportionnée de la
biométrie la lutte contre le
détournement des procédures le
renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières et la dynamisation de la
politique d'éloignement la lutte contre
les filières qui exploitent la précarité
et la fragilité des personnes souhaitant
s'établir sur notre territoire
participant ainsi à la traite des êtres
humains et également prioritaire dans le
même temps il convient de veiller aux
conditions d'application de la
législation en matière d'entrée et de
séjour des étrangers en apportant un
appui permanent au services qui
instruisent et délivrent les titres de
séjour et en veillant en conditions
notamment de délis dans lequel sont
examiné les demandes de délivrance et de
renouvellement des titres de séjour
l'accent doit également être mis sur la
garantie du droit d'asile le droit
d'asile est une exence une exigence
pardon constitutionnelle un engagement
international au titre de la Convention
de Genève et une obligation du droit de
l'Union européenne en 2022 l'pra dont je
salue le le remarquable travail fourni
depuis de nombreuses années a reçu plus
de 131000 demandes d'asile un chiffre
sans précédent positionnant la France
comme 2uxème pays d'accueil en Europe
derrière
l'Allemagne parmi les les objectifs du
plan d'action gouvernement garantir le
droit d'asile et mieux maîtriser les
flux migratoires du 12 juillet 2017
figure celui d'améliorer le traitement
des demandeurs d'asile et les conditions
d'accueil des demandeurs le renforcement
des moyens dédiés a produit des effets
significatifs c'est le cas pour le
premier accueil et l'enregistrement de
la demande d'asile dans les guicherss
uniques pour demandeurs d'asile en 2002
en 2022 ce dél s'est élevé en moyenne à
4,1 jours en raison de l'accueil des
déplacés d'Ukraine mobilisant fortement
les préfecture ainsi que par une forte
augmentation de la demande d'asile au
cours du dernier quadrimestre 2022 ce
délai a toutefois progressivement
diminué pour s'établir à 3,1 jour entre
janvier et août 2023 soit au niveau
légal de 3 jours il est également noté
que le renforcement des capacités
d'accueil se poursuivra en 2024 avec la
création de 1500 places supplémentaires
pour les demandeurs d'asile et les
réfugiés aussi une attention
particulière mérite d'être porter sur
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
irrégulière euh régulière pardon
excusez-moi l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour du premier titre de séjour lui
donnant voocation à séjournner
durablement en France ou l'obstention du
statut de réfugié bénéficiaire de la
protection internationale dans le cas
des demandeurs d'asile l'étranger primo
arrivant s'engage dans un parcours
personnalisé d'intégration républicaine
concrétisé par la signature d'un contrat
d'intégration républicaine sur les
plateformes d'accueil de l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration dit Lofi avec plus de
110000 contrats signés en 2022 jamais
les attente en matière de politique
d'intégration on été aussi
élevé chaque année environ 100000
étrangers issus de pays tiers à l'Union
européenne signent le contrat
d'intégration républicaine le contrat
d'intégration républicaine est la
première étape du parcours d'intégration
personnalisée de l'étranger en France il
consacre des des engagements réciproques
en particulier l'apprentissage du
français et l'appropriation des valeurs
de la République le comité
interministériel à l'intégration du 5
juin 2018 a doublé le volume d'heur de
formation linguistique et civique
dispensé dans le casadre du CIR
accentuer accentuer la nécessaire prise
en compte de l'insertion professionnelle
des étrangers primo arrivants dès leur
premier mois de leur arrivée en France
et ce au niveau local en déployant des
moyens accrus pour les territoires au
fin de développement d'action visant la
levée de frein à l'accès à l'emploi et à
la formation des
EP par ailleurs il s'agit d'adapter
l'immigration régulière aux réalités
économiques et sociales de notre pays à
la nécessité de renforcer son
attractivité tant en faveur des
étudiants internationaux que pour la
recherche des profils hautement
qualifiés pour les secteurs innovants
par exemple les mobilités étudiantes
justement intern international sont un
levier d'attractivité et d'influence
pour notre pays il est ainsi nécessaire
de trouver l'équilibre entre un objectif
quantitatif et un objectif
qualitatif ce sont nos besoins
scientifiques et économiques qui doivent
nous accompagner dans cette démarche là
concernant l'ctivité économique et
touristique les initiatives ont été
multiplié ces dernières années qui en
plus des réformes structurelles font de
notre pays la première terre d'accueil
des projets d'investissement créateur
d'emploi en Europe madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous exposer les moyens
complémentaires pour la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine en 2024 et et
vous prévoyez un budget de laad
supérieure aux prévisions de nombre de
demandeurs d'asile pourquoi merci Madame
edvich Diaz pour le groupe rassemblement
national merci monsieur le président
madame la secrétaire d'État chers
collègues Auel de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros d'économie possi
relativ à l'immigration je pense
notamment à la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence nous proposons d'autres
mesures fortes permettant de sauvegarder
d'importantes sommes pour l'État c'est
ainsi que parmi les amendements que nous
défondrons aujourd'hui on retrouve une
économie de 200 millions d'euros visant
à ne plus traiter les demandes d'asile
sur le sol français mais directement sur
le territoire du pays de départ nous
proposons également d'allouer 100
millions d'euros prévus à l'accueil de
migrants dans ce projet loi de finances
à la création de nouvelles places en
centre de rétention
administrative de plus nous souhaitons
baisser les dépenses insensé comme le
versement d'aide qui encourage
l'immigration économique qui AB bondit
de 45 % entre 2021 et 2022 et
d'augmenter les fonds alloués à la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière en
effet entre 600000 et 700000 étrangers
en situation irrégulières sont présents
sur notre sol c'est autant que la
population totale de la Charente Marie
ou encore des pirénées atlantiques ce
chiffre est glaçant surtout quand ils
sont mis en parallèle avec celui des
obligations de quitter le territoire
français qui ne sont pas exécutés tout
le monde le sait à peine 5 % d'exécution
d'qtf en 2021 autre postees de dépenses
délirant les associations le montant des
subventions versées aux associations
immigrationnistes explose en 2016 la
France leur accordé 306 millions d'euros
en 2022 94 81 millions d'euros sont
venus aband les caisses de ceux pour qui
l'immigration devient un business
lucratif cette dépense incompréhensible
finit de montrer l'hypocrisie d'un
gouvernement avare avec les Français à
l'euro prês mais dilapideur avec des
association immigrationniste ces
associations n'ont pourtant pas besoin
d'autant de moyens elles disposent déjà
de relais à l'Assemblée nationale avec
la nupess qui dépose des amendements
tous aussi farfelus les uns que les
autres tels que l'augmentation du
montant de l'allocation pour les
demandeurs d'asile la création de place
d'hébergement d'urgence supplémentaire
pour les demandeurs d'asile la création
d'une nouvelle dépense pour un fond de
soutien aux hébergeurs solidaires et
demandeurs d'asile et réfugiés ou encore
ils le disent clairement la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papi la gauche a définitivement tourné
le dos à la défense des classes
populaires le texte que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui et qui sera
rejoint par le projet de loi immigration
annoncé depuis plus d'un an déjà sera la
source de mécontentement de français
pendant l'année 2024 comment pouvez-vous
vous prévaloir de fermeté en matière
d'immigration alors que vous refusez de
mettre fin au regroupement familial ou
au droit du sol comment pouvez-vous dire
que vous protégez la population alors
même que l'expulsion des clandestins des
délinquants et des criminels étrangers
n'est pas systématique comment ne pas
croire que l'immigration est un projet
macroniste quand vous refusez de
réserver les aides sociales aux Français
et que vous transformez ainsi la France
en guichet social pour migrants
l'immigration que vous financez et même
organisé fait exploser tous les postes
de dépenses de l'État et de toutes les
collectivités à commencé par les
départements qui doivent faire face au
déferlement de mineurs non accompagnés
dont près de 40 % seraient de faux
mineurs selon un rapport sénatorial et
dont le coût serait près de serait de
près de 50000 € par an et par mineur
pour toutes ces raisons il est bien
normal que 78 % des Français aent une
mauvaise opinion de la politique menée
par le gouvernement en matière
d'immigration mais je veux dire à ces
Français légitimement inquiet qu'en 2027
lorsque le rassemblement national
arrivera au pouvoir la politique qui
sera menée sera drastiquement différente
je vous remercie ministre faudra pas
assez d'une demi heure pour démonter
toutes ses contevérités madame Andr Tor
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
monsieur le Président 12 12 c'est le
nombre de condamnations de notre pays
pour traitement inhumain et dégradant
pour avoir enfermé des enfants avec
leurs famille dans les centres de
rétention cette indignité internationale
est à l'image de votre budget il prépare
le terrain d'une loi qui criminalisera
toujours plus les étrangers et démolira
le droit d'asile vous préférez gonfler
les crédits du programme immigration et
asile en poursuivant je cite la
dynamisation de la politique
d'éloignement et oui il faut bien
construire ces 11 cras supplémentaires
et porter la capacité de rétention à
3000 places pour satisfaire les
désidératas racistes d'éic Coti et du
rassemblement national vous enfermez
plus plus vite et plus longtemps alors
même que vous êtes un incapacité
d'éloigner les personnes retenues pour
des raisons juridiques et diplomatiques
qu'importe si les associations
démontrent depuis des années que la
prolongation de la rétention n'a aucun
effet sur les chances d'éloignement de
la personne retenue surtout quand la
rétention a été faite sans discernement
le 20 octobre dernier une française a
été libérée du cras de mil lamelot pour
y avoir été enfermé pendant 5 semaines
c'est la conséquence de votre politique
de délivrance d'qtf à Touva absurde et
dangereuse vous renforcez les services
en préfecture en créant 8 ans pleins
pour poursuivre les travaux
préparatoires des espace France asile
cette territorialisation insensée de
l'OFPRA que le projet de loi d'armanin
prépare demain les fonctionnaires de cet
organisme seront en grève pour dénoncer
leurs conditions de travail au moment où
vous vous apprêtez à compresser les
délais de traitement des demandes
d'asile vous créditez donc des actions
qui n'ont pas encore été voté la
prochaine fois supprimer le Parlement
non la loi d'armanin n'a pas été adoptée
par cette assemblée cette loi ne trouve
pour l'instant aucune majorité donc je
sais que vous n'hésiterez pas à
l'imposer par par force par la force à
coup de 493 ce qui est déjà le cas pour
le projet de loi de financeces 2024
votre fuite en avant répressive masque
mal l'indigence de votre politique
d'accueil les crédits àoués à
laallocation pour demandeur d'asile sont
en chute libre mo-s 10 % par rapport à
2023 alors que les projections font état
d'une augmentation des demandeurs à
venir ils avaient déjà été réduits de 36
% l'année d'avant vous clochardisez
notre système d'accueil en le rendant
défaillant et indigne les demandeurs
d'asile sont de moins en moins logés
dans les structures d'accueil 70 %
étaient hébergés en 2023 et il ne serait
plus que 64 % en 2024 le financement de
50 3 3000 places est insuffisant le
milieu associatif et la solidarité
citoyenne tentent tant bien que mal de
combler les défaillance de la puissance
publique l'état laisse des collectivités
territoriales démunies dans les
territoires qui connaissent de fortes
tension en matière
d'hébergement Médecin du Monde vient de
publier son rapport annuel mettant en
évidence que 8 personnes sur 10 éligible
à l'aide médicale d'État n'y a pas accès
vous préférez développer la
matérialisation de bout en bout afin
dit-on de fluidifier les processus et de
réduire les délais ou plutôt de faire
des économies sur le dos de certains
usagers du service public qui ne je cite
mériteraient pas un accueil humain en
préfecture celles et ceux qui souffrent
déjà de la fracture numérique elle et
ils se trouvent maintenu en situation
précaire voire perdent leur titre de
séjour et subissent des ruptures de
droit les conséquences nous les
connaissons risque d'interpellation en
cas de contrôle policier difficulté à
accéder à un emploi à la formation aux
études et aux droits sociaux ce budget
appuie des politiques publiques
inhumaines elle renvoie les gens dans la
précarité laisse les autres dans
l'indigence la plus totale vous
comprendrez que nous nous y opposerons
fermement juste juste un mot pour vous
dire que la lopni a été votée et que je
parle de la prochaine par que c'est sur
la lopie et que c'est sur la lopmie que
se fonde le financement des cras dont
vous parlez
monsieur Éric poet pour le groupe les
républicains oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur madame la
ministre quand arrêterons-nous de
financer ce qui nous empêche d'expulser
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
et qui pour certains d'entre eux
deviennent des
terroristes dans une tribune publiée la
semaine dernière la directrice de
l'ifrapp Agnès Verdier molignier
alertait sur le dévoiement et l'absence
de transparence des subventions
publiques versées aux associations de
protection des étrangers qui font tout
tout pour empêcher leur expulsion y
compris lorsque ces derniers
représentent un risque terroriste pour
la France avéré en effet malgré le
salafisme affiché par la famille du
terroriste Mohamed mogoukov qui avait
fait l'objet d'une tentative d'expulsion
du territoire français en 2014 la simade
ù le Réseau éducation sans frontières
ont tout fait pour empêcher son
expulsion madame la ministre la France
est fière d'être une terre d'asile mais
elle ne peut devenir une terre de
terroriste sur l'hôtel de nos valeurs
humanistes dévoyées
alors que l'État consacre à peine 63
millions d'euros pour essayer d'éloigner
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
et que seulement 7 % des ooctf sont
exécutés il choisit dans le même temps
de verser 980 millions d'euros à des
associations qui s'efforce de faire
annuler ces
décisions cette disproportion
inacceptable entre les moyens alloués à
la défense des demandeurs d'asile qui
sont 15 fois supérieurs à ceux destinés
à la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière appelle un rééquilibrage
d'urgence comme le proposera le
président Eric cotti lors de l'étude des
amendements madame la ministre face à
l'opacité qui règne autour des
subventions publiques versées aux
associations de défense des étrangers le
ministère de l'Intérieur pourrait-il
communiquer à la représentation
nationale le registre de ces subventions
en nous précisant qui sont les
bénéficiaires et quelles sont les
actions qui ont été conduites avec ces
fonds publics qui représentent presque
la moitié des crédits de la mission
immigration asile et
intégration par ailleurs madame la
ministre le ministère serait-il prêt à
être auditionné par une mission
d'information parlementaire afin de
rendre des comptes sur l'utilisation de
ces crédits qui appellent à plus de
transparence je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon
pour le groupe
démocrate je vous mercie monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur la mission budgétaire
immigration asile intégration pose avec
acuité le délicat problème de
l'équilibre entre les aspects régaliens
et les aspects humanitaires de la
politique
publique ce débat renvoie des questions
très concrètes autant de sujets qui
structurent la ligne de conduite du
gouvernement laquelle consiste à veiller
et à garantir que l'apport migratoire
soit accepté et acceptable les crédits
que nous examinons
aujourd'hui traduisent budgétairement
cette double volonté maîtriser une
immigration régulière tout en luttant
contre l'immigration irrégulière
en cohérence avec
laalopliie ces crédits sont les
globalement en légère hausse au-delà des
modifications de nomenclature qui
pourrai rendre difficilement perceptible
l'évolution des efforts du gouvernement
en leur faveur et si nous avions nous en
avions le temps nous pourrions décrire
la réalité chiffrée des flux migratoires
et se loin des tensions idéologiques
suscitées par les arrivées récentes de
migrants à lampedouza et au canaris en
2022 près d'un million de personnes ont
demandé l'asile dans l'Union européenne
soit le plus fort afflux observé depuis
2016 2è pays d'entrée la France est
également le second pays européen en
demande d'asile derrière l'Allemagne et
juste avant l'Espagne depuis la fin de
la crise sanitaire on observe donc une
reprise généralisée des flux migratoires
en Europe et particulièrement en France
le gouvernement en a tiré très vite les
conséquences en allouant des moyens
budgétaires supplémentaires à la
politique d'asile qui représente
désormais les 2/ers des crédits de la
mission on envoie d'ors et déjà les
premiers effets positifs le traitement
dans des délais raisonnables des
demandes d'asile autre mesure positive
avec le déploiement du programme agir
doté de 30 millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires cette année
l'accompagnement immédiat durable et
personnalisé des étrangers auxquels il
est demandé de signer un contrat
d'intégration républicain les premiers
résultats obtenus par le rééquilibrage
territorial des demandeurs d'asile que
l'État s'efforce de structurer par le
guichet unique départemental
d'intégration et le concours des
préfectures sont encourageants et
positifs néanmoins se pose la question
de la participation des élus dans le
dispositif national d'accueil et le
nouveau schéma d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile et d'intégration des réfugiés
pensez-vous madame la ministre
généraliser la consultation des élus
dans tous les départements j'en viens à
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière bien sûr dont les crédits
sont en très forte progression en raison
de l'augmentation de 30 % du nombre de
places de centres de rétention
administrative conformément d'ailleurs à
la lopmie ce qui va nécessiter le
recrutement de nouveau personnel dans
les de cras que j'ai pu visiter face au
manque d'effectif l'externalisation de
certaines missions y compris celle de
surveillance ainsi que le développement
de recrutement d'agents au profil
polyvalent à la fois administratif et de
sécurité ont été soulevés d'où ma
question la création de nouvelles places
s'accompagnet-elle d'une réflexion sur
l'évolution des profils et du statut des
futurs personnels madame la ministre
j'aurais voulu vous interroger sur
d'autres points mais je vais avant de
conclure si j'en avais le temps je
voudrais vous interroger effectivement
sur les difficultés qui résultent de la
forte augmentation du nombre de mineurs
accompagnés ou encore sur la mise en
œuvre d'une
à l'échelle européenne notamment avec le
nouveau pacte asile immigration vous le
savez notre groupe est très
favorable comme nous sommes favorables
d'ailleurs à ce budget je vous remercie
madame marami pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègues la mission asile
immigration comporte donc deux
programmes le 303 immigration et asile
et le 104 intégration et accès à la
nationalité française donc les crédits
de de la missie sont globalement en
augmentation mais l'évolution est
contrasté entre programme et action
ainsi le programme 303 connaît une
augmentation significative des crédits
de paiement qui passe de
1,465 milliards d'euros à 1,725
milliards d'euros soit une évolution de
18 % et l'action lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière voit ces
crédits augmenté de 91 millions contre
il est vrai 139 millions euh d'euros
pour l'action garantie de l'exercice du
droit d'asile le document programme
annuel de performance indique que je
vous cite 306,7 millions sont versés à
l'OFI en provenance du programme 303
immigration asile dans le cadre de la
gestion de la location pour demandeur
d'asile dont 6,5 millions de frais de
gestion le programme 104 value aussi ses
crédits baissés de 21 % passant de 543
164 millions de en dans la loi de
finances initiale de 2023 à
431,150 millions au projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 donc si je rappelle
ces ces éléments c'est parce que si
l'évolution des crédits des
interrogation forte existe à la fois sur
le montant des dépenses consolidées en
matière d'immigration d'asile
intégration et sur le révolution toutes
les dépenses ne sont pas agrégées et
consolidées et en l'espèce les crédits
de DESC activité territorial souvent en
première ligne pour accompagner les
migrants et répondre aux besoins ne sont
pas rapprochés de ceux de l'État il en
va donc de même de ceux de l'Assurance
Maladie cela rend difficile donc une
approche objectivée des crédits et de
leur évolution face aux besoins sur les
politiques suivies je me contenterai de
faire quatre observations importantes
sur laada déjà cité ce montant parît
très stable ce qui pose à la fois la
question du nombre de bénéficiaires mais
aussi celle du montant de la
laallocation lui-même alors que les
dépenses contraintes de tous les foyers
augmentent en période d'inflation il
convient de rappeler qu'en 2022 les
crédits de laad étaient de l'ordre de
491 millions soit un demi milliard cette
stagnation qui suit une baisse très
importante renvoie donc à la question de
la continuité des politiques suivies par
l'État en 2016 laad quasi équivalent à
celui d'aujourd'hui concerernit 85000
demandes d'asile alors qu'en 2023 ce
seront vraisemblablement 135000 demandes
qui seront en jeu ma question madame la
ministre donc est comment expliquer que
la D n'est vu plus l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile un retard non
rattrapé les chiffres disponibles en
terme de plac proposé font état de la
création en 2024 de 1000 places
d'hébergement pour demandeurs d'asile
dont 500 en cada et 500 en CAES au l'OPF
2023 4900 places supplémentaires été
annoncé pour les demandeurs d'asile à de
comparaison le nombre de places créées
en 2000 entre 2015 et 2017 a été de
15000 le PLF 2020 n'a écré aucune alors
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous dire
quelle est la capacité réellement
installée et pas seulement arrêtée par
vos vos soins à ce jour et quel taux de
de couverture réalise-t-elle par rapport
aux besoins effectivement mesurés dans
chaque département et au plan national
je voulais aussi rappeler sur
l'apprentissage du français le document
portant projet annuel de performance
évoque à juste point l'essentiel que
constitue l'apprentissage du français
par les migrants et pour leur bonne
intégration il évoque également à quatre
reprises néanmoins ce même document est
extrêmement lacunaire sur le sujet et
n'offre ni vision globale ni évaluation
sommaire des efforts faits et surtout
des résultats obtenus donc Madame la
Ministre pouvez-vous évoquer ce point
dans vos réponses que je souhaite qu'il
puisse être le plus circonstancié merci
Monsieur Didier Le Maire pour le groupe
horizon
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues malgré une baisse des
autorisation d'engagement il est à noté
une hausse de plus de 7 % des crédits de
paiement pour 2024 sur la mission
immigration asile et intégration il
s'élève ainsi à plus de 2 milliards
d'euros le programme immigration et
asile concentre la quasi-totalité des
crédits consacrés à cette mission le
groupe horizon et apparenté salue les
deux marqueurs de ce budget à savoir
d'une part l'accélération du délai
d'instruction des demandes d'asile
déposé par a pardon àofpra qui est parmi
les plus maîtrisés des États-membres de
l'Union européenne malgré une
augmentation du nombre de demandes
attendues en 2024 155000 soit une
moyenne de 13000 décisions par mois la
déminition du délai d'instruction doit
se poursuivre il s'élevait en moyenne
autour de 260 jours en
2020-2021 contre 159 jours en 2022 et
121 jours au 1er semestre 2023
d'autre part ce budget poursuit les les
efforts engagés en matière de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière c'est
en effet une augmentation de plus de 50
% du budget consacré pour
2024 depuis 2017 plus de 700 étrangers
radicalisés ont été expulsés en 2 ans
plus de 90000 titres de séjour ont été
retirés ou refusés et 3200 étrangers
représentant une menace pour l'ordre
publ ont été expulsés cet effort doit se
maintenir et le groupe horizon et
apparenté salue le plan ambitieux porté
par la lopmie d'ouverture de plac en
cras afin de porter le parc à 3000
places d'ici fin 2027 ces 3000 places
s'ajouteront aux 1959 places existantes
au sein des 26 cras que compte notre
territoire à ce titre la problématique
de la construction de cras se rapproche
de celle des établissements
pénitentiaires si l'idée d'en construire
davantage recueille un soutien fort les
possibilités d'implantation sont limité
contenu souvent des réticences locales
pourriez-vous nous indiquer madame la
ministre à quel stade nous en sommes
concernant la construction de ces 3000
places supplémentaires l'état a-t-il
dans son dialogue avec les collectivité
trouver des lieux d'implantation pour
terminer mon propos je souhaite rappeler
que l'intégration est un aspect central
de la politique migratoire de la France
avec 100000 étrangers issus de pays
tiers à l'Union européenne qui signent
un contrat d'intégration républicaine
les efforts en matière d'apprentissage
de la langue doivent être poursuivis et
relevés à un niveau A2 voire B1
le groupe horizon et apparenté se
réjouit par ailleurs que plus de la
moitié de ces crédits soient mis à
disposition des préfets de région
contenu de la nécessaire
territorialisation pardon des politiques
d'intégration le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera en faveur de cette
mission budgétaire telle qu'elle est
proposé je vous remercie monsieur Julien
Baillou pour le groupe
écologiste merci monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur madame la
secrétaire d'État madame la rapporteur
l'a dit le budget est en baisse en
particulier sur la garantie du droit
d'asile et l'intégration des étrangers
et donc nous écologistes ne pouvons que
voter contre ce budget c'est un triste
avant-goût de la situation pour les
étrangers dans ce pays avec le projet de
loi qu'on peut appeler daranin qui a été
évoqué par madame la secrétaire d'État
je voudrais me concentrer sur trois
points d'abord les centres de rétention
vous vous vantez d'en augmenter le
nombre de places mais quiconque a pu en
visiter et je vous invite à le faire
évidemment et vous auriez pu constater
des rétentions illégales des expulsions
illégales et un problème général d'accès
au au droit on parle en fait
d'enfermement de personnes innocentes et
donc il y a aucune justification aucune
et en particulier ça a été évoqué la
France a été condamnée à des dizaines de
reprises par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme sur l'enfermement des
enfants en centre de rétention
administratif des enfants innocents et
parfois des bébés et c'est une majorité
qui se dit humaniste qui le permet et
qui l'a renforcé depuis de 2018 donc on
appelle évidemment à la fin de
l'enfermement de de tous les mineurs de
moins de 18 ans en France et y compris à
Mayotte sur la régularisation je
voudrais insister sur le fait qu'on a
besoin d'une régularisation massive en
particulier des travailleurs sans papier
pour leurs droits et leur dignité et
pour lutter contre le dumping social
malgré eux ces personnes pèsent sur les
salaires de l'ensemble des Français et
des Françaises là c'est la toute la
société qui gagne à ce qu'ils obtiennent
des droits il y a toutes les études
Concorde en particulier la grande
régularisation opérée par François
miteron en 1980 permis d'augmenter les
salaires et c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que le Front National est
contre lui qui refuse systématiquement
d'augmenter les salaires trème point on
en parle peu mais en fait en France on a
transformé nos préfectures en fabrique
de machines en machine à fabriquer des S
papiers on a transformé nos préfectures
en machine à fabriquer des S papiers C
fautes de rendez-vous on stresse des
étrangers qui sont réguliers sur le
territoire qui stressent pour le
renouvellement de leur titre qui
crainent pour leur statut et c'est à
l'origine d'un contentieux qui embolise
en retour les tribunaux administratifs
qui croulent sous les recours 40 50 %
des tribunaux administratifs des cours
administratifes d'appel qui croulent 50
% de recours pour faire annuler des
décisions des TF illégales ou pour des
recours visant à contraindre
l'administration à donner des
rendez-vous et ensuite un nouveau
recours pour faire exécuter la décision
c'est complètement cavecayen et donc
nous proposons une mesure simple un
délai maximal comme pour les passeports
talents pour renouveler ou pour
autoriser les titres et puis une
reconduction tacite pour le
renouvellement voilà qui va simplifier
la vie de de nombreux habitants et des
agents en préfecture et puis enfin euh
je voudrais dénoncer ici le le petit jeu
vraiment minable qui se tourne autour de
ce projet de loi immigration on a
d'abord le Front National qui est tout à
son habitude qui instrumentalise
l'horreur qui utilise la stratégie du
vautour ou du charognard sur des drames
qui secouent notre pays pour alimenter
des thèses erronées et puis on a la
droite qui lui court après et je vais le
dire la majorité qui fait pas beaucoup
mieux ça fait 1 an un an et demi qu'on
nous parle de ce projet de loi et
pendant ce temps-là rien n'est fait pour
toutes les urgences économique et
sociale du pays non un an et demi que la
majorité fait la danse du ventre pour
obtenir quoi les voix de Monsieur marlex
et de ses amis alors que vous savez
parfaitement qu' finira par vous lâcher
je le sais vous le savez lui le sait
tout le monde le sait c'est pathétique
alors que pendant ce temps-là je
rappelle qu'une majorité de français
estime à raison que l'immigration est
une richesse et que les travailleurs
sans papier sont ici chez eux au
contraire je vourrais saluer justement
l'action de la CGT qui a soutenu une
belle grève des S papiers il y a
quelques jours qui a conduit à la
régularisation de centaines de personnes
sans papier j'ai pu je termine là-dessus
j'ai pu m'entretenir avec le patron
d'une agence d'intérim qui a priori
votait pas écologiste je lui demander
qu'est-ce que ça a changé pour lui la
régularisation de ses travailleurs il
m'a dit rien mais je comprends que pour
eu ça change tout voilà régularison les
travailleurs s monsur David ran pour le
groupe gauche démocrate
républicaine merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues on nous présente aujourd'hui
un budget en hausse ce n'est pas nouveau
c'est un budget qui est tiré vers le
haut depuis déjà quelques
années ce qui est nouveau c'est la
politique migratoire que ce budget
contribue à décliner et depuis 2017
cette politique est marqué à la fois par
une dégradation des conditions d'accueil
et d'accompagnement mais aussi par des
atteintes é aux droits fondamentaux et
pour terminer par des traitements
dégradants et en particulier à l'égard
de l'accueil des mineurs isolés
étrangers un arrêt en particulier doit
être rappelé ici à notre bon souvenir
car il contribue un peu à imager la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve et
à questionner nos priorités celui c'est
celui rendu en juillet 2020 par la CEDH
c'est cet arrêt de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme condamne la France
pour les conditions d'existence
inhumaine et dégradante de demandeurs
d'asile vivant dans la rue 3 ans plus
tard à Cayenne place des amendiers les
demandurs d'asile s'entassent encore et
toujours dans la rue dans des conditions
misérables et indignes car oui les
territoires d'autrre mè sont entièrement
dépourvus de Kada et si la présentation
du programme 303 annonce la création de
nouvelles places de Kada de son
d'accueil d'examen de situation
administrative et de centre provisoires
d'hébergement elle précise aussi que ces
mesures s'inscrivent dans le schéma
national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile et d'intégration des réfugiés
pour rappel ce schéma qui fixe la
répartition des places d'hébergement n'a
jamais été
décliné dans les territoires ultramarins
qu'en sera-t-il pour son renouvellement
sur la Pée 2024 2027 je rappelle à titre
d'exemple que la Guyane concentre tout
euh tout de même l'essentiel des
demandes d'asile déposé en autre mère il
serait donc un peu plus normal qu'elle
figure dans les régionalisations de ce
schéma pas de centre de rétention
administrative en notre maère non plus
du moins pas partout à la place on
privilégie les locaux de réttenion
administrative je rappelle que tout de
même que les LRA que les LRA doivent en
principe être utilisé uniquement lorsque
des circonstances particulières
empêchent un emplacement en cras c'est
le cas en Martinique et à Saint-Martin
qui ne dispose pas de cras ou à Mayotte
ou des l provisoires sont régulièrement
créés du fait d'un CR complètement
saturé l'absence d'accompagnement
effectif dans les LRA on fait des zones
de non droit et il n'est pas rare que
des personnes placées en LRA soient
reconduites à la frontière sans qu'elles
aient pu avoir accès à une assistance
juridique notons toutefois qu'à défaut
d'annoncer la création demandé de
longues dates de centre d'accueil pour
demandeur d'asile dans nos territoires
ultramarins le ministre Gérald amanin a
annoncé l'implantation d'un cras
supplémentaire à Mayotte restons
optimiste on peut se dire qu'au moins
les étrangers qui qui sont fermés ne
s'ileront plus les uns sur les autres
mais restons aussi réaliste c'est avant
tout le signe qu'on privilégie les
dispositif d'enfermement et de
répression à ce visant l'accompagnement
et l'intégration les chiffres de ce
budget parlent de même une lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière au moins
démultiplié versus une dotation baisse
du programme dédié à l'intégration et à
l'accès à la nationalité française et
des autres m encore une fois mis de côté
j'appelle toutefois mes collègues
députés à aller se pencher sur les
nombreuses mesures dérogatoires à
l'œuvere dans nos territoir ultramarin
que ce soit en matière de structure
d'hébergement de traitement accéléré des
demandes d'asile de droits sociaux au
Rabé ce qui est en place à titre
expérimental chez nous n'est que le
reflet de ce qui sera bientôt proposé
d'appliquer chez vous merci à tous et
enfin pour les non inscrits madame
Menard madame Emmanuel Ménard
pardon merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'ai plusieurs
questions très précises en fait première
question pouvez-vous me préciser le taux
d'exécution des ocutf en 2022 et quand
je vous demande le taux d'exécution
c'est pour avoir un rapport entre les
exécutions d'cttf simple et celle après
passage en en cras deuxème question
pouvez-vous nous donner des chiffres
précis sur les laisser passer
consulaires et notamment sur ceux
accordés par les trois pays du Maghreb
trè question les forces de sécurit
nous rappelle fréquemment leur
difficulté à exécuter les otf alors que
le délit de séjour illégal n'existe plus
en France pouvez-vous nous assurer que
le rétablissement de ce déli figurera
bien dans le futur projet de loi
immigration de Monsieur Darmanin
enfin quelques autres questions sur la
part de l'immigration économique par
rapport à l'immigration pour motif
familial on nous explique ces derniers
temps que l'immigration économique est
est plus importante que les autres je ne
crois pas que ce soit enfin les chiffres
dont je dispose ne ne le démontre pas
j'aurais voulu avoir vos chiffres à vous
euh question sur les associations en
2022 on l'a dit 981 millions d'euros ont
été versés à destination des
associations qui a de l'immigration et
notamment l'immigration clandestine
comment justifiez-vous une telle somme
alors que certaines associations ont
clairement pour objectif de s'opposer à
l'action de l'État en matière de lutte
contre l'immigration illégale euh une
autre question sur les demandeurs
d'asile au total l'OFPRA et la CNDA ont
rendu
56179 décisions favorables d'attribution
de l'asile en 2022 ce qui représente
41,8 % de l'ensemble des décisions rendu
dès lors se pose la question de la
situation des 60 % de déboutés et selon
un rapport de la Cour des comptes de
2015 96 % d'entre eux resteraient en
France après le rejet de leur dossier
avez-vous et je finirai là-dessus des
données plus prè plus récentes sur le
nombre de déboutés qui reste en France
en 2023 je vous remercie alors madame la
ministre vous avez la parole pour
répondre aux orateurs des
groupes merci monsieur le Président donc
moi je vais essayer de faire dans
l'ordre histoire d'être précis et concis
euh madame la rapporteur donc vous
m'interpelliez sur
eu les 300 millions
sanctuarisés au titre de laad sur
l'accueil donc de 160000 donc c'est une
prévision 160000 demandeurs d'asile et
on est on a sanctuarisé à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros pour pour arriver à peu
près à 180000 € 180000 pardon demandes
donc ce c'est une prévision alors qui
est en qui est en qui est en hausse mais
on prévoit on a vraiment essayé de de se
dire les demandes sont en baisse mais on
met un budget en hausse donc voilà donc
pour vous répondre
précisément sur laad euh je je
reviendrai tout à l'heure député mendz
sur votre question qui relie la première
interpellation de la de la rapporteur
sur le le programme 104 donc en fait non
c'est pas une diminution du programme
104 c'est juste que les 27 millions
d'euros c'est une différence de
recherche de ressources on ira les
chercher au fonds européens plutôt que
des sanctuirisé d sanctuirisés au niveau
du PLF donc c'est pas une baisse c'est
juste on va récupérer l'argent au niveau
des fonds européens qui sont là qui sont
disponibles donc ça concerne pour être
tout à fait précise 27 millions 27
millions d'euros et et voilà donc c'est
une augmentation voilà de la dotation du
fond d'asile que vous connaissez
migration et intégration à la femme donc
pour la période
2021-2027 après donc nous sommes ah oui
voilà c'est vrai vous me vous
m'interpellez aussi madame la rapporteur
sur la maîtrise de la langue
effectivement c'est essentiel
euh et je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres pour vraiment répondre parce
qu'il me semble que plusieurs d'entre
vous ont posé la question euh des
mesures nouvelles donc sont doté à
hauteur de 7,5 million d'euros sur 2024
euh dans son budget initial 2023 l'OFI
avait programmé 87 m00,5 en tout des
dépenses au titre de formation
linguistique donc c'est et pour 2024 9
millions sont prévu pour les seules
formations A2 B1 sur Lofi donc ça c'est
euh voilà vous vouliez euh les chiffres
et vous avez raison de rappeler
l'importance de l'apprentissage de la
langue pour les demandeurs euh pour les
demandeurs d'asile euh je reviens sur la
question du député Mendes donc les
moyens complémentaires monsieur le
député sur la lig donc la lutte contre
l'immigration euh clandestine 15
millions d'euros sanctuirisés dans le
PLF et je rappelle juste un programme
signé avec les Britanniques sanderst qui
qui est un montant conséquent de 540
millions d'euros pour protéger nos
frontières donc voilà et c'est des
moyens effectivement on est bien obligé
de se de se coller euh aux nouvelles
technologies donc euh voilà je voulais
rappeler l'accord avec euh nos amis
britanniques euh sur sur ce sujet de de
lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine madame torinha euh madame la
députée donc je vous réponds entre 2017
et fin 2024 euh le nombre de places euh
euh de places encra donc c'est euh on va
arriver à 202 enfin fin 2027 à 3000 en
tout euh on peut considérer que c'est
pas assez vous avez le droit de penser
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça représente
environ 60 millions d'euros 60 million
d'euros par an donc environ vous
considérez oui non mais j'ai compris
mais en attendant on en a besoin vous
avez le droit de penser que c'est trop
mais on en a on en a besoin sinon on
essaie de proposer d'autres dispositifs
mais il faut bien essayer de gérer le
flux donc de demandeurs d'asile donc qui
ne sont plus non mais qui ne sont plus
qui ne sont
plus qui ne peuvent pas rester donc je
vous donne donc sur 2000 2023 donc le le
nombre de de places
121230 places don don
11400 en CPH donc vous vouliez un
chiffre tout à l'heure je l'avais noté
je je vous le donne
euh donc sur les oui les
octf donc le ministère de l'Intérieur
donc a repris fortement et vous vous
comprenez bien que les les relations
diplomatiques sont primordiales surtout
dans ce contexte euh je vous donne juste
un chiffre sur des des étrangers
menaçant l'ordre publique on est aux
alentours de
3600 3615 euh et et la réalité c'est que
si on travaille pas sur les laisser
passer consulaires avec les pays avec
lesquels on on peut encore discuter la
Russie par exemple c'est la triste
réalité de notre
oui ben 3615 éloignement en 2022 je je
le précise et sur le taux d'exécution
des
OQTF la réalité c'est que si on
travaille pas sur les laisser passer
consulaires et si on narrive pas bah oui
mais ouais mais il faut bien reprendre
les discussions là où elles ont été
laissées je sais plus qui parler des
pays du Maghreb il y a des pays avec
lesquels on peut discuter d'autres vous
le savez très bien non donc les
relations diplomatiques sont importantes
je sais plus lequel d'entre vous me
l'avez dit c'est vrai euh ensuite sur
pardon voilà merci voilà euh sur les
subventions aux
associations
alors ce sont des associations qui qui
officient donc un service de un service
public je rappelle le chiffre et je vous
le donne en tout transparence sur 2024
c'est 1 milliard pour aider ben on
parlait en parlant de la Simat c'est 4,2
million d'euros elles ont une mission
fondamentale de service public
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'asile
elle elles opèent pour l'État après si
le débat doit être est-ce que quand une
quand le droit a rendu son jugement
est-ce qu'elles doivent intervenir moi
je pense que non mais la réalité c'est
que le service public qu'elles opèent
est très important je je sais plus qui
parlait de la simade mais je voulais
apporter cette précision euh des choses
que l'État confie à des à des
associations quand même qui ont pour
mission d'accompagner des des réfugiés
des demandeurs d'asile sur notre
territoire moi je pense que c'est c'est
important puisqu'elles ont cet ADN là
après je pense effectivement que leur
mission s'arrête là à l'accompagnement
et une fois que le droit est rendu les
sujets le droit doit reprendre toute sa
place euh sur l'externalisation monsieur
le député Mandon euh des missions Kra
donc sur l'externalisation ce que je
crois est ce que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a dit et a rappelé c'est que
de ramener la police à son donc les les
policiers qui opèent en CRRA àors
première fonction c'est-à-dire la
sécurité maintenir la sécurité au centre
des au centre au creux si je puis dire
des centres de rétention c'est leur
mission première et externaliser par
exemple je vous donne deux exemples
l'accueil euh donc vraiment l'accueil du
public et par exemple la blanchisserie
ouais je pense qu'on peut externaliser
cela et il me semble que nous avons si
je ne dis pas de bêtises à peu près 10
millions d'euros d'augmentation de
budget sur cette externalisation des des
services en CR mais ça me paraissait ça
me paraissait
fondamental et je pense que la police a
cette vocation là je vous rappelle
juste madame Tor je reviens sur votre
question et c'est voyez je l'avais bien
noté sur la chaîne de droit dans la
demande
dématérialisé euh quatre passages en
préfecture pour quelqu'un qui n'a pas
forcément comme vous le disiez les
moyens de se dé placacer les moyens je
pense que commener à dématérialiser je
vous rappelle juste le budget 56
millions d'euros euh sur 96 mois et
éviter à tout le monde de se déplacer en
préfecture parce qu'on sait que c'est
compliqué parfois il y a même des
ruptures de mobilité vous le savez pour
je pense que c'est pas mal d'avoir aussi
des plateformes dématérialisées où on
peut faire des démarches on le fait pour
nos concitoyens on peut faire une
demande voilà de de passeport et en
préfecture et en préfecture et en
préfecture les préfectures donc déjà les
préfectures ne sont pas sous-dotées par
contre elles forment des agents à
l'accès au numérique c'està-dire que
quand la personne le demandeur d'asile
se déplace il peut être aussi accompagné
sur sa demande dématérialisée moi je
pense que c'est plutôt plutôt une ouais
c'est plutôt une c'est plutôt une
avancée écoutez si on viveait dans un
monde parfait je vous garantis que tout
le monde le saurait ici euh la réalité
c'est que dématérialiser ce genre de
demande moi ça me paraît important euh
et d'être accompagné enfin éviter quatre
passages et arriver à un ou deux
passages en préfecture en terme de
confort pour l'usager je pense que
c'est c'est pas mal alors les délais de
traitement donc des procédures traitées
sous la nef sont singulièrement réduits
al je donne voilà aux procédures
classiques 17 jours en moyenne pour les
titres étudiant 13 jours pour les
passeports talents je sais plus qui
parlait des passeports talents et 10
jours pour les autorisations de travail
donc on reste dans des délais de plus en
plus raisonbles mais vous avez raison il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin sur euh
sur ce sujet concernant
euh alors pardon voilà
alors la réponse à voilà l'implantation
des cras monsieur le député le maire
euh depuis 2017 donc vous le savez dans
la lmie nous avons sanctuarisé c'est le
fameuse amendement sur ti 3000 places en
CR euh 10 10 sites ont été déterminés
justement pour pouvoir les installer
parce que c'est bien de dire on a 3000
places mais où est-ce qu'on les met si
vous me le permettez je vous donne les
sites qui ont déjà été localisés et
c'est euh ces sitesl sont finalisés euh
dans le désort donc Dijon Oissel Nant
pour ceux qui s'intéresse Bézier exan
Provence goussinville Nice Oliver
Olivier Olivé pardon mrigac euh à
Mayotte aussi
euh monsieur le député Ran et ainsi que
dans le dunkerercois donc c'est euh
c'est sans place à peu près par par CR
donc voilà je pense que c'était aussi
auss important une fois qu'on a validé
le fait d'avoir ce budget supplémentaire
et ces places en plus de trouver leur
localisation alors
euh je sais plus voilà blab bla bla
voilà non les mineurs qui a parlé ouis
je suis obligé de dire blab bla bla
parce que ah oui monsieur député Bou
ouais absolument euh vous parlez aussi
des des mineurs enc ils sont très très
minoritaires enfin vous pouvez pas dire
que non mais j'en ai écoutez j'en ai un
à côté de chez ma mère au cané à
Marseille dans le 14e je les ai visité
comme vous mais pas pour des raisons
politiques je travaillais sur ces
sujetsl il me semble pas avoir été
frappé par le nombre de mineurs enc
enfin vous parliez et sur 2022 oui
oui 108 mineurs accompagnés donc si vous
voulez le chiffre vous voulez un chiffre
vous l'avez donc 10 ouis je vous le
redonne et voilà alors et
une vous m'avez interpellé aussi sur le
projet de de loi le prochain projet de
loi
immigration ce projet de loi interdira
la rétention en centre enc des mineurs
donc voyez on répond à une
de écoutez on discutera de ça mais
écoutez moi moi j'adore j'adore le débat
on débattra je vous dis ça ça arrive
dans pas très longemp termine la
r gardez vos vos forces pour ce débat là
on en aura BES Besin mais en tout cas ce
qui est ce qui est sûr c'est et vous
l'avez vous avez raison parce que moi je
le pensais de toute manière les mineurs
effectivement il faut trouver une autre
solution donc est-ce qu'on doit aller
plus loin on en débattra mais en tout
cas les dans le prochain projet de loi
les mineurs ne seront plus enc et je
pense que c'est une très bonne mesure là
c'était juste pour vous répondre alors
attendez on pourra débattre madame ou on
va on va vous laisser la ministre
répondre euh et voilà donc je crois
avoir répondu monsieur le président à
moins que j'ai ah oui pardon il y a
Monsieur ran qui se manifeste et après
on pourra passer aux questions allez-y
madame la ministre non non
non donc vous avez terminé madame la
ministre euh si sur la D je vous j'ai
répondu les CADA je vous ai pas répondu
sur les les CAD al on va vous répondre
euh donc la réalité c'est que vous le
savez mieux que moi vous êtes un député
de là-bas euh la situation enfit on peut
pas dire que dans le ministère au
ministère de l'intérieur on ne prend pas
en compte les autres maires vous pouvez
pas me dire ça à moi sur les CADA est-ce
qu'il faut plus est-ce qu'il faut mieux
vous avez raison de de le dire moi je
pense que oui et est-ce que sur le
prochain je vous invite on va débattre
dans le prochain débat immigration qui
arrive dans pas longtemps à l'Assemblée
je vous invite à déposer plutôt plutôt
que de de pas vous mais plutôt que de
perdre notre temps à se dire qu'on est
pas d'accord essayons de tomber d'accord
sur sur des sujets parce que je j'ai
beaucoup été interpellé notamment à
Marseille par par des amis qui
travaillent beaucoup sur ces sujets là
donc oui sur les cadav vous avez raison
on a un sujet est-ce qu'on répond
exactement à la demande c'est il est
vrai que non je vais pas vous dire là
devant la représentation nationale
est-ce que c'est assez je ne crois pas
et je le je suis d'accord avec vous
est-ce qu'on doit aller plus loin oui
comment est-ce qu'on sanctuarise et
qu'on évalue tout ça vous savez très
bien que l'immigration irrégulière vous
le savez que ce soit à Mayot que ce soit
c'est ce sont des sujet quand je dis un
peu à part parce que la situation
géographique fait que c'est un petit peu
à part donc monsieur le député riman moi
j'aimerais beaucoup avoir ce débat avec
vous lors de de la la présentation du
projet immigration mais vous avez raison
sur le fond merci Madame la Ministre
alors j'ai différents inscrits pour des
questions de 2 minutes chacune on
commence par Monsieur Johann Gillet pour
le groupe alors Monsieur Johann gilet
pardon ce n'est pasateur de groupe je
donne la parole allez-y voilà oui merci
monsieur le Président Madame la la
secrétaire d'État comme membre du
gouvernement comme élu de Marseille vous
le savez le lien entre immigration et
insécurité est établi prenons l'exemple
de la cité faosséenne 55 % des actes de
délinquence y sont le fait d'étranger la
délinquence y est d'ailleurs en hausse
de près de 11 % chez vous comme ailleurs
comme anime sur ma circonscription comme
à Nant à Paris à Lyon le bilan de votre
Ministre de tutelle est mauvais c'est
factuel et alors que partout en France
la délinquence et l'ensauvagement de la
société pourrissent la vie des français
le PLF 2024 que présente le gouvernement
s'inscrit dans la continuité la
continuité de l'échec madame la
secrétaire d'État 96 % des obligations
de quitter le territoire ne sont pas
exécuté alors qu'en France on dénombre
une agression tous les 44 secondes alors
qu'aujourd'hui on dé nombre 120 attaques
à l'arme blanche par jour et puisque le
lien entre immigration et insécurité est
établie puisque les exemples de
personnes sous octf qui commettent des
délit des crimes des actes de terrorisme
sont malheureusement si nombreux
qu'attendez-vous pour réagir au-delà de
l'aspect purement juridique parfois
diplomatique il y a l'aspect pratique
madame la secrétaire d'État pourtant
Emmanuel Macron s'était engagé à
atteindre 100 % d'exécution des
OQTF chers collègues il faut ouvrir les
yeux madame la secrétaire d'État on vous
y invite assez d'assassinat assez de
viol assez d'agression gratuite assez de
vol les Français en ont assez et veulent
que l'immobilisme cesse en l'occurrence
vous nous parliez tout à l'heure des des
crédits budgetés pour pour répondre
favorablement aux ucttf l'on constate
quand même que dans vos documents
budgétaires il n'y a aucun objectif fixé
en terme de réalisation de ces otf
mettre de l'argent en plus c'est bien et
c'est nécessaire mais il faut une réelle
volonté et afficher un objectif clair et
dire oui on expulse faut et j'en finis
monsieur le Président il faut un message
clair au pays qui refuse ou qui refuse
madame daniel
benau Merci monsieur le président madame
la secrétaire d'État je voudrais vous
réinterpeller sur la problématique de la
dématérialisation des procédures en
matière de droits des étrangers qui a
été d'une certaine manière à un terrain
d'expérimentation à une généralisation
ensuite sur l'ensemble d'autres
politique entre 2018 et 2022 les
réclamations auprès de la Défenseur des
droits portant sur les droits
fondamentaux des étrangers sont passés
de 6400 euh 6540 à
21666 une hausse de 231 % qui est en
bonne partie lié justement à ces
procédures de de dématérialisation des
guichets préfectoraux avec notamment le
déployement des modules de prise de
rendez-vous en ligne les sort de la
plateforme déjà démarche simplifié censé
permettre d'effectuer l'intégralité du
dépôt à la demande de titre de séjour en
ligne et le développement de la
plateforme nationale administration
numérique des étrangers en France la nef
les ressortissants et ressortissances
des paystiers de l'Union européenne sont
les plus durement touchés car et Lil
doivent réaliser des démarches en ligne
sans alternative possible pour se voir
reconnaître un droit au séjour et au
cours des dernières années les
procédures qui leur sont imposées ont
connu un grand nombre de
dysfonctionnement structurel entraînant
d'importantes ruptures de droit pour les
personnes concernées des modules de
prise de rendez-vous saturés des
accompagnements adapté tout inadapté
tout cela pour conséquence de maintenir
euh ces personnes dans une situation
précaire voire de les placer dans une
situation irrégulière ça a déjà été
évoqué puisque elle ne dispose pas de
l'ensemble des éléments leur permettant
de déposer une demande la Défenseur des
droits a souligné que le téléservice
dans sa forme obligatoire et sans
alternative dématérialisée était source
de grave atteintte au droit qui engendre
un contentieux de masse devant les
tribunaux or par deux décisions celle de
novembre 2019 et du 3 juin 2022 le
Conseil d'État a contracré deux
obligations pour les pouvoirs publics
proposer un accueil et un accompagnement
aux personnes en difficulté avec les
démarches numérisées et prévoir une
modalité de substitution pour
enregistrer ces demandes en cas de bug
du téléservice ma question madame la
secrétaire d'État est de savoir comment
vous allez mettre en œuvre ces décisions
de la justice en matière
démériisation merci Monsieur le le
président madame la ministre d'abord une
remarque effectivement sur l'accueil en
préfecture on est très très loin de la
perfection on compte plus dans nos
circonscriptions les personnes qui
viennent nous voir parce que soit elles
ont perdu leur emploi alors qu'elles en
avaient un et qu'elles étaient en
situation régulière deux qui ont une
carte de séjour en attente et qu's l'ont
une fois qu'Al est périmé ou trois qui
se retrouvent avec des récissés pendant
2 ans et demi ce qui les empêche sur
beaucoup de leur droit et de leur
déplacement donc vraiment parler de on
est loin de la perfection c'est quand
même très très loin de la réalité de ce
que vivent ces étranger en situation
régulière depuis de nombreuses années et
pour ceux qui cherchent ardemment à
lettre deuxème chose ma question elle
est sur sur les centres de de rétention
puisqu'on voit dans dans le budget que
on a une large baisse du programme 104
qui lui est sur l'intégration et l'accès
à la nationalité française alors que
celui sur la lutte contre l'immigration
régulière connaît une forte hausse du
fait de la création du du nombre de
places en cras supplémentaire puisque
vous avez fait vous avez validé quelque
part la vision de droite et d'extrême
droite en validant la le la demande de
de Monsieur sooti de création de place
supplémentairirees en cras sans même
regarder ou essayer de regarder les
conditions dans lesquelles sont retenus
les étrangers dans ces centres de
rétention il y a très nombreuses
condamnations à la fois sur
l'enfermement des enfants mais aussi
pour les adultes voyez les conditions
dans lesquelles ils sont aujourd'hui
retenus alors qu'ils sont innocents nous
avons là des personnes qui sont dans des
prisons pour étrangers simplement sur le
fait qu' qu'ils sont étrangers donc
avant d'augmenter les places nous on
pense que faut tout bonnement les
supprimer mais quand vous dites que vous
augmentez les places à quel moment vous
êtes allé regarder comment ces places
supplémentaires aller faire coïncider
droit réponse aux droits fondamentaux et
autre chose je vous permets pas de dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans le projet de loi qui
nous est présenté il y aurait
l'interdiction des de l'enfermement des
enfants puisque c'est 16 ans de 16 à 18
ans ils sont encore mineurs et vous
autorisez encore à Mayotte et dans les
locaux de rétention
administratif alors c'est c'est tout
même une disposition de l'article 12
aujourd'hui que vous avez décrite madame
fossillon pardon madame emilliie
Chandler madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commission des lois face au nouveau défi
migratoire le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités pour mieux accueillir et
intégrer les réfugiés et les talents
tout en luttant contre l'immigration
irrégulière les plus migratoire reste
important leur maîtrise demeure un enjeu
essentiel la question ne se lie pas
seulement à l'échelle nationale mais à
l'échelle européenne dès lors l'Europe
et la France doivent dans le même temps
lutter davantage contre les passeurs et
les complices dans la continuité des
efforts déjà entrepris ces dernières
années le PLF 2024 consacre des moyens
en hausse au dispositifs d'intégration
des étrangers et l'enveloppe globale des
crédits d'intégration continue de
progresser de 3 % dans le PLF 2024 après
une hausse de plus de 24 % l'an passé
ces efforts budgétaires traduisent la
volonté d'avoir en France une politique
migratoire en réduisant les délais
administratifs tout en protégeant mieux
ceux qui sont dans le besoin et en
renvoyant ceux qui ne correspondent pas
aux valeurs de la République
l'intégration des étrangers en France
est un enjeu de premier plan de cohésion
sociale aussi vous êtes devant nous pour
présenter les crédits de la mission
immigration asile intégration ma
question madame la ministre est donc la
suivante comment garantir une meilleure
intégration des étrangers primau
arrivant sur le territoire madame la
ministre je vous
remercie monsieur Tom aménager
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors je vais continuer dans la
foulée de mon collègue poet et de ma
collègue Ménard en 2024 donc vous venez
de nous annoncer que ça serait 1
milliard d'euros qui serait versé par le
ministère de l'Intérieur à des
associations ces associations sont pour
la plupart orientées politiquement
koalia et franc TER d'asile pendant CIT
2 sont dirigé respectivement par deux
élus nupes actuel élus madame cos et
Madame najade valallot Belkassem
certaines d'entre elles s connu ont
détourné de l'argent public l' ancien
directeur général descoalis percevait un
salaire de 18000 € mensuel bénéficiit
d'une voiture de 90000 € il disposait
également d'un logement de fonction donc
en gros pendant que le DG desqualis en
fait roulait en audiq7 c'était les
Français qui payaient le prix
d'immigration massive et la voiture de
ce monsieur cette association a touché
en 2021 plus de 12 millions d'euros des
pouvoirs publics c'est-à-dire en fait à
titre de comparaison 12 millions d'euros
c'est le montant qui est donné pour
redynamiser le commerce rural chercher
l'erreur pour prendre un autre exemple
en détail ça a été cité la simade a elle
est-elle subventionnée à hauteur de 6,4
millions d'euros et céit pas moi qui le
dit c'est le DG de l'OFI qui le dit did
leskii qu'il y a aujourd'hui je cite une
difficulté pour l'État c'est que des
associations comme la sad postulent à
des marchés publics comprenant un cahier
des charges précis alors qu'une partie
importante de leur salariés est
fondamentalement hostile à la politique
publique qui correspond à ce cahier des
charges pire on le sait ça a été dit la
SIMAD a été une des associations qui a
empêché l'expulsion de la famille
mogoukov en 2014 dont le fils a tué le
professeur Dominique Bernard il y a 15
jours il y a 10 jours en bref en fait on
subventionne des associations qui
s'infilent dans les cras pour faire du
sabotage et détourner la loi et mettent
en danger les Français par pure
idéologie madame la ministre je vous le
dis c'est pas du service public le
service public c'est l'intérêt général
ces gens-là ils ne défendent pas
l'intérêt général ils défendent une
idéologie ils n'accompagnent pas
absolument pas les demandur d'asile leur
donent des récits préédigés pour
détourner l'État de droit et pour nuire
aux Français donc est-ce que vous pouvez
confirmer que vous allez continuer à à à
nourrir ces subventions et ces personnes
et que vous n'allez pas remettre en
place du contrôle et retirer les
subventions à tous ceux qui jouent
contre la France contre les Français
contre notre sécurité je vous remercie
madame Elisa
Martin euh bon bonjour à tous merci de
me donner la parole dans dans la
continuité de ce qui a été dit par par
Elsa fusson c'est vrai qu'on a une on a
des interrogations majeures autour de la
question de la rétention
administrative qui quoi qu'il en soit si
ces centres sont sont développé et bien
évidemment on y retiendra ou enfermera
un certain nombre de personnes ça ça
nous engage et on les remplira c'est ça
que je veux dire pardon et ça ça nous
engage au moins sur sur deux plans euh
le premier c'est la question des
principes et ça fait partie ces cras
font partie des raisons pour lesquelles
nous sommes condamné pour pour lesquels
la France est condamnée particulièrement
par les instances européennes et il est
vrai que quand on exerce notre droit de
visite en tant que parlementaire d'une
part évidemment on est toujours surpris
par ces situations d'absence de
possibilité d'aller venir mais on est
aussi tout de même fort
euh étonné par le fait que la France
assume de retenir des gens dans de
telles conditions non respect de de de
la vie privée
empilement non accès à un certain nombre
de droits d'activités et en plus petite
serie sur le G pardon de la la formule
que j'utilise et qui il est vrai fort
fort trivial c'est que lorsque nous
sommes allés un certain nombre et
d'ailleurs ma chère voisine était à côté
de était avec moi euh et avec
Jean-François coulom on nous a quand
même empêché d'accéder aux locaux euh du
cras de saint-exupéri dit 2 qui bien
qu'il soit le 2e n'est pas dans un état
formidable et donc il a fallu attendre
3h pour que nous puissions exercer notre
droit de visite qui me semble-t-il est
tout à fait clair clair dans la loi donc
il y a bien la question des principes et
de la situation dans laquelle ce la
France se met lorsqu'au fond elle ne
respecte en rien les droits fondamentaux
et la question de l'efficacité
évidemment se pose merci Monsieur flier
oui merci Monsieur le le Président je
voudrais quandême réagir au propos de
Elsa fusillon et Elisa Martin et pardon
parce que je leur tourne le dos
je peux pas les les voir en leur parlant
sur la question de la rétention
administrative il y a au contraire mes
chers collègues un changement de nature
de la rétention administrative en France
elle était autrefois indistincte dès
lors que la personne avait une TF et
nous sommes au contraire dans une
stratégie très ciblée qui consiste à
privilégier la rétention administrative
pour les personnes qui ont commis des
délits ou des crimes ou qui sont si
chose dire et pardon pour l'expression
expulsable c'est-à-dire pour lesquels
nous avons un espoir de laisser passer
consulaire Vous dites les conditions
sont mauvaises elles sont pas toujours
bonnes ça je vous confirme et je vous
interrogerai madame la ministre sur le
cras de Bordeaux dans quelques
instants mais s'il y a précisément un
unjeu capacitaire sur les cras c'est
parce que nous voulons aussi en
améliorer les conditions d'accueil et de
rétention et ça c'est une réalité et la
France au cours des dernières années
contrairement à ce que vous avez indiqué
n'a pas été condamné sur les conditions
de rétention elle a été sur les enfants
en 2012 en 2016 pas récemment parce que
de depuis ces dernières années il n'y a
plus de rétention de famille avec
mineurs raison pour laquelle raison pour
laquelle nous pourrons vous proposer
dans quelques semaines l'interdiction de
la rétention pour les mineurs de moins
de 16 ans et nous pourrons d'ailleurs
discuter de l'élargissement de cette
temporalité de cet âge en tout cas nous
y sommes nous y serons prês sur sur le
cras les cras il y a des cras qui
méritent précisément des augmentations
capacitaires pour donner des conditions
de rétenstion beaucoup plus décente et
digne et Madame ministre parle en
particulier du CR de Bordeaux le CR de
Bordeaux c'est 25 places en sous-sol de
l'hôtel de police ce sont des conditions
qui sont inacceptables et très récemment
à la fois les retenus et les agents de
forces de l'ordre de la en particulier
ont souhaité faire une grève
savoir ques sont l'intervention
quinvention que vousez faire Stéphan
rambau très bien bonjour
oui oui merci monsieur le Président
bonjour madame la secrétaire d'État la
Cour des comptes dans son dernier
rapport relatif à l'analyse de
l'exécution budgétaire a pointé une
sous-utilisation significative et
inquiétante des crédits consacrés à la
lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière pour l'année 2022 concernant
l'action 3 lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière bien que
57,3 millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et
64,4 million en crédit de paiement est
été alloué pour l'éloignement des
étrangers irréguliers seul 36,3 millions
en AE et 31,3 millions en CP ont
finalement été engagés traduisant une
sous-exécution de 366 pour les AE et de
51,4 pour les CP face à la situation
migratoire chaotique de la France ces
chiffres sont plus
qu'alarmants les déclarations fermes de
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
l'immigration sont en décalage avec les
réalités territoriales et
budgétaires la sous-utilisation
apparente des fonds alloués témoigne
d'un renoncement du gouvernement et du
président de la République face à la
problématique de l'immigration massive
les millions de français et de français
victimes directes ou indirectes des
conséquences de l'immigration sont
abandonnés à leur triste sort madame la
secrétaire d'État à la lumière de ces
éléments et dans le cadre de la mission
asile et immigration du PLF 2024 comment
comptez-vous assurer une meilleure
exécution des crédits dédiés à
l'éloignement des étrangers en situation
régulière commentz vous concrétiser les
paroles du ministre de l'Intérieur en
action pour répondre aux préoccupations
des français concernant l'immigration
massive et les enjeux de sécurité qui en
découlent Monsieur Antoine
léomand merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues madame la ministre
parler d'immigration c'est parler de la
France parce que depuis la Révolution
française l'invention du drapeau
tricolore de La Marseillaise et de la la
Constitution de 1793 nous avons défini
le peuple français comme étant un peuple
citoyen et républicain et non un peuple
ethnique puisque en 1783 nous donnions
la citoyenneté aux étrangers au bout
d'un an et que en 1848 nous avions même
abaissé le seuil à 6 mois de résidence
sur le territoire national or vous
décidez de baisser les crédits
d'intégration à et d'accès à la
nationalité française vous les faites
passer de 54 à 43 millions d'euros
comment voulez-vous faire des français à
partir des immigrés si jamais vous
baissez ces crédit d'immigration or
faire des français à partir des immigrés
c'est l'histoire de la ville de
Marseille dont vous êtes originaire
Marseille qui est né il y a 2600 ans du
mariage d'un Grec et d'une princesse
gauloise Marseille qui nous a donné nos
vignobles depuis l'étrangers qui font la
fierté de la France Marseille qui a été
conquise par Rome et qui nous a donné
notre langue actuelle Marseille qui a
été la ville d'accueil des réfugiés des
guerres de religion Marseille qui a été
la ville rebelle à l'autorité des rois
Marseille qui a donné le nom à notre
hymne national en envoyant les fédérés
marseillais en 1792 participer à la
Révolution française Marseille qui a été
la ville de la commune de Marseille
Marseille qui a été la ville de
l'immigration italienne dont je suis
moi-même originaire Marseille enfin qui
s'est libéré par elle-même par
l'insurrection des Forces Françaises de
l'Intérieur mais aussi par la
participation des Tirailleurs Algériens
et des goumiers marocains qui ont
participé à la libération de la ville
Marseille enfin qui a été la la terre
d'accueil de la décolonisation madame
faire des Français c'est un peu
finalement faire des Marseillais puisque
marseille est une ville créole et je
pense que en augmentant ces crédits
plutôt qu'en les baissant vous feriez
œuvre utile pour l'intérêt général et
pour notre
nation alors non non non on n'applaudit
pas Monsieur Philippe gostin oui merci
Monsieur le le le président madame la
ministre j'associe à à ma question à mon
propos Éric Coti Éric pooget qui sont
tous les deux députés de de scène des
des des Alpes Maritimes oui en en 2021
le le 21 septembre la renationalisation
du du RSA en scène Saint-Denis a été
validé ce qui montre à titre
expérimental par le Premier ministre de
l'époque qui était Jean Castex ce qui
montre que c'est une décision de
renationalisation pour une politique
publique locale qui peut-être possible
et je voudrais vous interroger sur cette
compétence ena mineur non accompagné qui
aujourd'hui pose bien des difficultés
au au département il y a une explosion
du nombre de MNA de ces mineurs non
accompagnés avec des difficultés de
gestion qui sont extrêmement compliqué
et si nous évoquons si j'évoque avec mes
collègues cette question de la
renationalisation c'est qu'en réalité on
demande au département de gérer des
difficultés ou un certain nombre de
dossiers sur lesquels ils n'ont
absolument pas la main puisque l'accueil
de ces jeunes se fait au nom de les état
par l'État et on voit bien qu'il y a
quand même un vrai sujet notamment par
rapport à la réelle minorité alors on en
a déjà parlé il y a quelques semaines
ici avec les tests osseux mais on a
quand même des révélations intéressantes
qui ont été faites ce weekend dans dans
Le Parisien et qui prenait appui sur les
exemples du Territoire de Belfort où on
avait sur 92 mineurs non accompagnés 68
68 d'entre eux qui seraient majeurs il y
a donc un détournement de l'esprit de la
loi accompagner les mineurs c'est une
chose les mineurs non accompagner c'est
une chose mais accueillir je vais
paraphraser paraphraser un ancien
Premier ministre toute la misère du
monde c'est tout à fait autre chose et
oui au vrais mineurs mais pas au au au
majeurs donc quelle est votre position
sur cette question de la
renationalisation possible je vous
remerci madame la ministre pour vos
réponses à tous ces
orateurs alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés donc je réponds encore une fois
dans l'ordre j'essaie autant que faire
ce peut mais alors parler des exécutions
donc des otf réels euh en fait ça veut à
peu près rien dire parce qu'en fait il y
a des recours comme on est dans un état
de droit il y a des recours possibles
sur lesqtf enfin c'est le droit est
ainsi et vous on aura l'occasion d'en
débattre justement dans le prochain
projet de loi immigration je vous donne
juste quelques chiffres
quelques chiffres de comparaison sur
2021 prononcé en terme d'qtf on est à
124000 111 exécuté
7488 sur 2022
134 134280 prononcés pour 9121 exécutés
donc on oui c'est les chiffres si vous
avez d'autres chiffres vous me les
donnez mais en tout cas ce c'est
mais il y a des recours monsieur le
député il y a des recours on peut pas
exécuter des UTF où il y a des recours
vous le savez mieux comment Monsieur G
mais j'ai essayé de vous répondre
monsieur le député gilet de la manière
la plus la plus honnête et la plus
sincère possible on ne peut pas exécuter
une TF où il y a un recours enfin c'est
le la base du droit euh concernant les
associations monsieur le député
ménager euh j'ai il me semble avoir
répondu et je je je rappelle que oui moi
je considère que c'est un service public
vous parlez de France Terre d'Asile
c'est un opérateur du service public et
la réalité c'est que puisque c'est
inscrit au PLF chaque année et que les
donc ce budget est sanctuirisé au sein
du PLF moi je vous invite alors puisque
vous n'êtes pas d'accord proposer des
amendements hein pour amender par
exemple ben merci merci merci euh vous
savez que vous pouvez le faire si vous
ne le faites pas à mon avis c'est que
vous devez avoir de très très bonnes
raisons ben oui puis que c'est inscrit
au PLF
euh madame la députée au bonau
concernant euh euh la dé
dématérialisation pardon sur les
demandes alors pour nos concitoyens vous
le savez je prends un exemple pour les
passeports vous le savez on a pris
beaucoup de retard les préfectures ont
pris de retard pas parce qu'elles n'ont
pas envie de travailler on s'est
retrouvé vous le savez mieux que moi
avec une demande post covid très
importante est-ce qu'il faut réduire les
délais vous avez raison et je vous donne
juste un chiffre vous avez raison et
puis je l'ai dit donc moi c'est assumé
bien sûr mais moi je je vous réponds
encore que je pense sincèrement que la
dématériation n'est pas la réponse à
tout mais le début de la réponse à tout
c'est-à-dire on peut leur on doit leur
permettre comme tous les Français de
pouvoir faire une demande sur internet
et je vous donne juste un chiffre au
niveau du guichet vous savez du du
guichet euh unique c'est 80 quand même
personnes qui s'occupent justement au
sein de la nef de traiter ces demandes
donc est-ce qu'on doit amplifier sur
l'année prochaine de toute façon vous le
savez euh les flux font que chaque année
on revient sur ces sujets là mais c'est
vrai on c'est c'est tellement vrai mais
moi je continue à penser que le
numérique est est un axe je je dis pas
que on peut pas mettre un agent par
personne par demandeur d'asile mais la
réalité c'est que si on arrive à
accompagner si on arrive à mettre les
moyens je rappelle encore les moyens 56
millions d'euros sur 96 mois vous me
direz c'est pass assé moi je vous dis
c'est le bon début en tout cas on a
compris qu'il y avait un sujet et on a
mis l'argent dessus et sur les sur les
délais sur les délais de manière de
manière générale effectivement qu'on a
un sujet en France sur le délai
d'obtention d'un titre quel que soit le
titre et c'est vrai qu'on doit amplifier
sur les demandeurs d'asile parce que ils
ont plus de problèmes que la moyenne
donc vous avez raison de le rappeler
mais je vous rappelle quand même que les
que les fils d'attente sont diminués je
rappelle quatre passages en PRF et si on
arrive à un ou deux en PRF parce qu'on a
réussi en préfecture parce qu'on a
réussi euh à à faire utiliser les ces
fameuses plateforme moi je trouve que
c'est une une une bonne une bonne
avancée euh sur
les cras euh je rappelle juste un
chiffre 95 % des personnes retenues en
CR sont des délinquants moi je veux bien
entendre beaucoup de choses ou sortant
sortant de prison monsieur le député ben
non mais non mais non mais si vous
voulez qu'on fasse le débat immigration
je peux le faire je suis prête mais
attendons
[Musique]
l'énord les
amend ver pour Le Rest vous pouvez ne
pas être d'accord rest sera le 27vemb
les les cras permettent quand même 30 %
de donc en sorti de CR on est à 30 %
d'éloignement donc la réalité c'est
qu'on est quand même bien obligé de
gérer vous l'avez dit ils ne sont pas
condamnés mais en attendant ils sont pas
non plus dans la légalité je sais plus
qui à un moment donné il y a il y a une
ex ENF il y a une situation irrégulière
et on doit bien la gérer on fait quoi on
les met en prison moi je pense pas moi
je pense que le CR reste quand même oui
bon enfin on peut débattre mais la
réalité c'est que la réalité c'est que
les personnes qui qui se retrouve en CRA
je vous le redis pour en avoir visité
quelques-uns et pas et non pas en tant
que député donc c'était un peu plus
compliqué pour y rentrer et du coup ça
me ramène à vous madame la députée
Martin il me semble que le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous AAZ répondu sur votre
visite dans ce CR mais il me semble bien
que vous soyez arrivé avec la presse et
qu'effectivement la oui mais la non non
non non non vous arrivez dans un centre
de rétention enfin et je vous donne là
un avis personnel il y a strictement
rien de prépar
moi non non vous arrivez quelque part
avec de la presse d'accord est-ce que
vous pensez pas que les gens qui sont
aussi à l'intérieur qui travaillent et
qui sont retenus n'ont pas droit eux
aussi ben un certain droit à l'image
vous connaissez le droit à l'image c'est
le droit à l'image c'est la base dans
dans le SI ouiou moi c'est ce que je
crois non mais c'est non mais vous
arrivez non je suis pas non ça je vous
permet pas alors après après après avoir
été traité d'un c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave allez j'accepte le
j'accepte on termine on termine
j'accepte d'être c'est pas un problème
non non mais c'est pas c'est pas grave
non non madame Martin vous ne discutez
pas avec la ministre on termine la
discussion générale merci ce que vous
voulez ça suffit euh monsieur mais c'est
pas grave c'est pas non mais je pas
franchement c'est pas ça suffit euh donc
monsieur le député bouier pour le CR de
Bordeau donc les travaux devraient
débuter donc en octobre 2024 je sais pas
si vous avez l'info mais je vous la
donne euh donc pour une mise en service
début 2000 2026 et vous avez bien fait
de m'interpeller sur les difficultés du
CR puisque j'ai eu accès à des données
et voilà il me tarde comme vous que les
travaux commencent donc 2 ans de travaux
sur l'ampleur de de ce cras c'est des
délais incompressibles vous le savez
mieux que moi donc je pense que c'est
voilà plutôt enfin une bonne nouvelle
mais vivement que les travaux commencent
et merci de m'avoir interpellé euh
monsieur le député léomemb sur Marse
merci pour votre Hyne à Marseille
j'aurais pas fait mieux euh et ce que
vous dites vous avez raison Marseille
s'est construite avec des vagues
d'immigration la plus vieille ville de
France 2600 ans d'histoire mais je vous
apporte pour être moi une enfant
d'immigré comme vous la réalité c'est
que notre problème et le ministre l'a
dit et je je paraphrase le ministre
Gérald harmanin le sujet c'est pas les
étrangers qui veulent non mais qui
veulent habiter enfin c'est pas à moi
qu'on va le dire qui viennent chez nous
et qui ont envie d'être français qui ont
envie de partager nos valeurs et de
vivre mieux que ce qu'ils pourraient
vivre chez eux c'est pour ça aussi on
oublie tout le temps de le rappeler
c'est ça le départ ils viennent parce
que chez eux ça va pas mais la réalité
c'est qu'on a un problème avec les les
personnes étrangères délinquantes vous
vous en conviendrez et les personnes
irrégulières on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas accepter dans un état de droit dans
un pays comme le notôre et de là où nous
venons tous les deux et aussi le
ministre Gérald Darmanin qui l'a rappelé
plusieurs fois en audition je l'avais
attentivement écouté on ne peut pas
lever enfin se passer au moins de cette
précision et euh et sur Marseille
puisque vous en parlez effectivement on
a on a su au fil des des millénaires on
va le dire
euh se construire grâce à cette identité
vous avez raison de rappeler que la
France même la France est construite
comme ça mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas règlementer parce que là où
il n'y a pas de droit là où il n'y a pas
vous le savez de règles on appelle ça
l'anarchie et c'est pour ça que les
étrangers viennent aussi chez nous enfin
justement ils fuiti chez nous ben parce
que chez eux je ne suis pas sûr que les
il fut des démocraties B voilà B
voilà oui mais sur la baisse des crédits
alors là là je vous avais répondu je
vous avais répondu non euh sur la baisse
des crédits vous vous ne pouvez pas dire
ça puisque on augmente sur chaque P
d'accord
euh vous vous parlez non non le Gard des
saau l'avait rappelé et très largement
vous ce que vous appelez on parle vous
parlez de combien vous me oui je connais
le programme 104 par cœur il y a un
transfert il y a un transfert vers le
programme 303 vous le savez je l'ai dit
vous n'étiez pas là mon propos
liminire pas un dialogue je lui
réponds voilà donc juste pour finir sur
bien bien être précis il y a un
transfert du programme 104 vers le
programme 103 ce que vous vous appelez B
moi j'appelle ça transfert de crédit
puisquil y aussi un transfert de
compétences voilà monsieur le
Président ah oui les MNA pour Monsieur
Po goselin et puis on pourra terminer
alors euh l'arrivée donc des mineurs non
accompagnés en France voilà est un
phénomène bon vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le député très précisément euh
phénomène connu depuis depuis voilà les
années 2010 vous avez bien rappeler la
chose la crise sanitaire donc a eu pour
effet de réduire fortement les flux
d'arrivées de MNA je vous le rappelle en
2020 et l'année 2022 et le début de l'
de l'année 2023 confirme la reprise
effectivement des arrivées
17780 euh de voilà mineurs accueilli oui
oui tout à fait le donc c'est 30 % euh
30 % de Haos sur 2023 le garde des saau
avait répondu et ce sujet relève et je
vous le dis puisque je puisqu'on parlait
de Marseille mais le sujet m'a été j'ai
été aussi interp été interpellé par le
Conseil départemental euh dans le 13 et
c'est ça relève en fait de ma collègue
Charlotte cobel donc j'adorerais vous
répondre là tout de suite mais c'est un
sujet un sujet à zeu et c'est chezz ma
collège Charlotte cobel je suis sûre que
si vous lui écrivez elle vous répondra
elle sera ravie de travailler avec vous
sur ce sujet primordial des enfants MNA
en
aze merci madame la ministre pour votre
audition merci c'est c'est c'est TER
dire c'est à elle de le dire je peux pas
répondre à la place de mes collègues sur
quelque chose qui ne relève pas de la
mission cette audition
voil je pouvoir accompagner la ministre
et on va passer à l'examen des
amendements je vous remercie et je
suspend une minute pour accompagner la
ministre